STUDENT: OK so basically,
the premise or our game
is we're essentially trying to
knock people out of the way.
They're coming
towards us and you're
moving as the first player.
And when they come too close
to you, they stick to you.
They stick to your screen.
[CLAPPING]
And you're trying
to move them out
of the way with your hand, which
is, right now, a cube object.
[LAUGHTER]
Because we couldn't find
any arms that were free.
STUDENT: And the functionality
isn't quite there yet.
We couldn't get the
gestures for it.
We were trying to
set up the game
and focus on colliders, because
that was giving us a hard time.
So I think that shouldn't
be too hard to implement
in the future.
But we can show you
what we have for now.
STUDENT: Oh, and yeah, we got to
this breakthrough in the past,
what?
20 minutes?
[LAUGHTER]
So one of that time that he
told us to [INAUDIBLE] computer,
we actually got
something to work.
So as of right now, it's
just kind of an animation
of things happening.
We haven't actually-- our mouse
moves, but doesn't do anything.
So it's just-- yeah.
Should I do maximize on play?
Oh yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
There it goes.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
Oh.
STUDENT: Oh.
There we go.
And that's probably
the end of it.
But yeah, we got the
people to stick in here.
That's the best.
[LAUGHTER]
And I think-- so
basically, how we
designed it is that
we had a cube object.
And we made that our trigger.
It's invisible.
It's only made of mesh.
Whatever.
PROFESSOR: Right.
STUDENT: Yeah.
And we made it invisible.
And so that whenever
people collide onto it,
the object gets destroyed.
And we have stuff already
pretty bare, as you can see.
And it's inactive beforehand.
So once someone collides,
someone appears.
So it's like someone
has stuck to you,
but no, people are
just already there.
But they disappear.